au 34e jour de guerre la diplomatie est
toujours aussi active nouveau round de
négociations ce mardi à istanbul en
turquie l'objectif a minima c'est de
résoudre les problèmes humanitaires le
but ultime c'est de décrocher un
cessez-le-feu stable bruno daroux
rebonjour restons très prudents les
négociations en tout cas semblent porter
leurs fruits alors écoutez on va oui
effectivement rester prudent mais enfin
il semble que ça commence à bouger de
part et d'autre parce qu'avant le
problème si vous voulez c'est que les
positions des deux parties étaient si
éloigné qu'on voyait pas vraiment
comment on pouvait arriver un début de
négociation là il semble que ça commence
à bouger
il ya eu des petites concessions de part
et d'autre c'est toujours comme ça côté
ukrainien le président hélène ce qui a
fait comprendre qu'il était acquis
désormais à l'idée d'un statut de
neutralité pour son pays qu'il propose
et voilà c'est ce qui a été redit ce
matin
des consultations sur le statut de la
crimée pour une période de 15 ans et que
pour le dombass là il continue à
réclamer la tête et territoriales mais
il se dit prêt aussi à des discussions
donc il ya eu quand même un petit un
petit mouvement de la part de vol et
recel à skis tout dépend évidemment il
appelle le statut de neutralité alors là
ce matin ce que les négociateurs
ukrainiens ont réclamé c'est que ce
statut soit garantie par des pays tiers
les quatre membres du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu mise à part la russie
bien évidemment c'est à dire les états
unis la chine la france et la grande
bretagne plus quelques pays plus
régionaux comme par exemple la pologne
l'allemand et israël notamment est la
turquie 1 qui joue donc un rôle de
médiation on le voit donc ça c'est
l'avancé côté cuisine avec quand même le
bémol très important c'est à dire qu'il
faut d'abord qu'il y ait un
cessez-le-feu et un retrait des troupes
russes et les pays qui garantirait le
statut de neutralité en fait ce serait
un mécanisme qui serait un peu validé au
niveau international qui prévoirait que
les pays dont je parlais si jamais la
neutralité de l'ukraine était mise en
cause il y aurait une intervention un
peu comme le fameux article 5 de l'otan
les ukrainiens veulent même que ça aille
plus loin donc ça c'est côté ukrainien
et puis côté russe aussi ça semble
bouger puisque le vice ministre russe de
la défense vient d'annoncer un retrait
des troupes russes à distance de kiev et
de czerny ghz qui se trouve au nord-est
de kiev donc dans le secteur nord du
pays c'est recoller les russes à accepte
visiblement de desserrer un peu l'étau
pas partout on l'a vu il reste
évidemment des villes comme marioupol ou
nikolaïev mais voilà il ya aussi une
concession de la part des russes à tel
point d'ailleurs que le négociateurs
ukrainiens estiment qu'une rencontre
désormais entre le président poutine et
le président zelensky serait possible
que les conditions sont désormais
suffisantes et toujours selon les
négociateurs ukrainiens la russie
réclame donc c'est l'histoire de la
neutralité que jamais au grand jamais la
l'ukraine a deja l'otan mais ne serait
pas opposé à une adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'union européenne ça évidemment ce
n'est que côté ukrainien qu'on le dit
pour l'instant bien voyez il ya des
choses qui commencent un peu
bouger quand même pas tous là ce doit
encore être au bout cela est très
fragile